hey guys it's January 25th I'm chastity
and I've got a bunch of news for you hot
off the press that's not a thing is it
how about the Internet yeah first up a
new update on project Scorpio Xbox boss
Phil Spencer has shed a little more
light on how project Scorpio is coming
along writing on Twitter Spencer started
off by talking about the games being
prepared to launch for the console quote
I don't think we've had bring up full
games this early for new hardware gives
teams time to tune their games for best
results he said in another tweet Spencer
was asked why he's even more
enthusiastic about the new console now
compared to when it was announced at e3
last summer actual games running where I
can see the fidelity on screen feel the
gameplay he said for me that's when it
becomes real Thomas smaller the CEO of
Ori and the blind forest developer Moon
Studios is also enthusiastic about
project Scorpio in a NeoGAF forum thread
the game director called Scorpio quote a
full-blown next-gen machine that's just
backwards compatible to your current
library in comparison mall are called
the ps4 pro a quote half-assed upgrade
Scorpio is due to launch this holiday
season but it remains to be seen when
Microsoft will start to show it off get
in the comments and let us know what you
think about project Scorpio next up pray
has a confirmed release date Bethesda
has announced pray will be available
worldwide from May 5th on xbox one ps4
and PC it has also released a new
gameplay trailer teased in the sci-fi
action game story which involves an
alien infestation on the telus one
research facility the video features
voiceover from protagonist Morgan you
who was involved in experimentations on
the aliens these organisms seem to have
the ability to shape-shift and the tests
change Morgan to the stowing him with
similar abilities after an outbreak
Morgan is tasked with containing and
eradicating the alien threat before it
can reach Earth Bethesda has also
announced the cosmonaut shotgun pack
preorder bonus which consists of Morgan
use family heirloom Margrave shotgun and
tools to fight threats aboard Tallis one
these tools are three Nura mods which
players can use to unlock new abilities
to med kits and a fabrication plan to
create the shot gun and ammo
there's also quote a starter kit for
building tools and weapons and a unique
upgrade to help players preserve their
limited resources and finally here's
when the Ghost Recon wildlands closed
beta starts the closed beta for Ghost
Recon wildlands will run februari third
26 Ubisoft announced today it will be
available on xbox one ps4 and PC with
preloading becoming available on
februari first you can sign up for the
closed beta on the games website though
there are no guarantees that you'll get
in if you do you can invite up to three
players on the same platform to the beta
the wildlands beta includes the province
of itaku ax in the near future bolivia
which is described as flourishing and
mountainous as ghosts players will work
together to take down key members of the
Santa Blanca drug cartel as they
dismantle the criminal organization
similar to the full game all the content
in the closed beta will be playable with
up to three friends via 4 player co-op
or in single-player wildlands launches
for ps4 xbox one and pc on march seven
2017 and if you want to learn more about
Ghost Recon wildlands please check out
our feature on six things we learn from
our time playing and if you liked this
video please leave us a like it really
helps us out I'm chastity and I'll see
you tomorrow
you
[Music]